this is a really high-tech dirt that we
had shipped all the way in from the
ground this how we do so what's up Ryan
you're gonna be test
I'm usually behind the camera but today
come on I'm in front of the camera dude
look how legit Alyx Vance looks right
now try to be legit yeah yeah I've been
in hard like hard combat you know I'm
like blocking like coming to RV oh yeah
these guys got armor I don't have
nothing
look you got the gravity gun I think
it's okay yeah all right all right and
just like grab all the bullets we first
started today by running as fast as we
can
yeah under there and all these I start
off the day running it's bad yeah I have
I start the day running at a OD oh yeah
sorry but they're coming out do you
think my god all of our damn
flying away and it's gone
we're basically motivating why you're
going underneath the bridge is because
something in the air trying to spot you
guys and come in sit down a date
sip it open it's gonna be a minute post
up guys stop tossing up yeah actually
just use a piece of cloth special fun
microfiber microfiber microfiber is
prevent the space-time fissure
so you take it go to the gun Oh take for
my whooping I'm upping box now we got
the protective gear I don't have it
anymore
no the Krista touches any part of that
gun are you I know
too soon multitude wears me to get to
space time okay I don't have it anymore
then you're after after you open this
box if the crystal you reach back to the
gun we're gonna have some screws open on
it so you twist it it's going to pop
open this parts a little delicate is the
actual gravity gun in two pieces you're
going to keep it on your knees a bit
gradle to be open let's go get back to
the combat here sorry yeah
thank my thing
drop back oh [ __ ] right there whoo one
hit in this shoulder turns this way
yells Alex
bang bang bang get shotgun boy whines
just goes down out of frame why have it
that complicated when you can just kill
them right here in one shot we can move
on good it is easy allows me CL out sees
the guy Oh No
get shot once we're losing the battle
and that's what possibly the call I keep
making like sound effects for my desk
okay keep me away yeah sure
I supposed to like how you would
actually sign which is like
[Music]
no I really wasn't great my arm is
really tired from holding the camera
sundown eCos arms Agia tired from
holding the camera it's now imagining
okay oh yeah I put that under the camera
as a trans prop it up thanks for the
heads up dude you go curl up in a ball
farm you may be able to hide I dare you
[Music]
all right good games rolling and Greek
exit
sloppier hey Jaime come on oh it's
pretty sweet I'm gonna do what Martin
let's do one more
it looks really good yeah BIGBANG
BIGBANG gravity
he just got reversed
I'll take it from
be careful baby just had an absolute
hanky in China you guys are and three
water - okay refill your cross like baby
will do it
there we go yeah cradle at night so you
love it
nice nice nice one or any neither pot of
water cameras rolling and three two one
action
that running shop
write a letter
all right that's it for that let me uh
PG played intend to go off bt-dubs 3d Co
okay you and he said hey you were like
hey I'm up there I'm gonna be right here
when I see the lines
give me some thousand yards stairs here
okay I'm like like I just saw war look
up again alright walk away with a little
bit haste that what's that in flying
they're going to get a ladder house it
looks like they're giving out it looks
like there's just like yeah that's the
way I find leaving with haste make sense
though you got everybody yeah
[Applause]
[Music]